habt ihr das im hausflur auch dass
kinder im haus für erst anfangen zu
heulen also wenn sie ja wahrscheinlich
meine jacke anziehen müssen und so und
wer hat schon bock seine jacke anziehen
zu müssen leute 2021 fängt schon mal gut
an es gibt einen muck bank mit den
besten donuts aller zeiten und zwar sind
diese donuts von bram iba donuts promi
balz donuts und jawohl mein promi ball
und das gute an den oder das beste an
denen es eigentlich dass sie alle
veganen sind bedeutet für mich die
laktose nicht so gut verträgt dass ich
hier absolut rein hauen kann und das ist
sehr selten ich bin ein sehr großer
freund von gebäck in jeglicher form und
jedes mal wenn ich halt frage ihr habt
ihr mich rein gemacht das ich darf ganz
oft halt nicht mit essen an der
kuchentafel und ganz viele veganer und
laktose intolerante können das
wahrscheinlich nachvollziehen
deswegen brami barcelona zweimal in
berlin seit haut rein ich weiß nicht ob
die noch mehr filialen haben ich glaube
im letzten jahren sie extrem expandiert
und bevor ihr jetzt was sagt diese
donuts werden natürlich verteilt also
das was ich nicht schaffe landet nicht
mögen also die begann sind boxer 30 euro
kostet allein schon aus dem grund würde
ich nicht wollen dass es im müller nicht
deswegen habe ich schon mal vorgesorgt
und weiß wo der rest an hinkommt und
damit ihr nicht eine halbe stunde lang
nur beim schmerzen zu hören ist habe ich
euch auf instagram darum gebeten jedoch
ein paar fragen zu stellen ich bin heute
quasi frau dr sommer
ich habe ganz kurz überlegt ob es mehr
weibliche form von doktor gibt aber ich
glaube das ist eine universelle
formulierung hoffe ich jetzt an dieser
stelle deswegen sage ich frau doktor
sommer
und ja ich bin gespannt was ihr denn da
sie ja okay es kam auf ja ich würde mich
schon als ekström ich schon mal sex
[Musik]
ich würde mich schon als
beziehungsexperte nennen ich war schon
in vielen beziehungen
ich bin zwar noch nicht so alt aber
erfahren
man konnte schon sammeln und vielleicht
gibt es ja den einen oder anderen tipp
den ich vermitteln kann der weiterhilft
und ihr seid natürlich herzlich
eingeladen euch jetzt was zu essen zu
holen denn ich weiss zurzeit ist man
viel alleine zu hause ich bin auch öfter
jetzt alleine gewesen und es macht
einfach spaß oder ein bisschen mehr
ja es gibt ein bisschen das gefühl nicht
allein zu sein wenn man mit jemand
anderem essen kann also pausiert jetzt
hierdurch war es und dann geht es auch
schon los und ich darf nicht mit dem
messe rumspielen wir müssen wie fangen
wir an
fangen wir mit dem mann der am wenigsten
aufregend ist ein zucker und zimt donath
also ein klassischer donath mit zucker
und zimt so groß dass ist er der erste
ich sage noch mal wieder von innen
aussieht falls ich jetzt sehr deutlich
ich habe das in letzter zeit öfter ich
weiß nicht woran es liegt also so dass
ich zweiter extrem naja was solls ich
glaube es liegt daran dass ich ein
laster ist sehr viele schwere sachen
heben
der geschmack ist super aber ein
bisschen blödes hand gefühl aber ich
glaube da muss man dann einfach mit sich
dass das muss das risiko geht man dann
ein den nächsten schlag nach da hab ich
doch ganz platten foto gemacht white
chalk strawberry ich weiß der sinn von
einem mob bank ist natürlich auch quasi
dass ich das alles hier esse ich schau
mal wie weit ich komme ich will mir halt
nicht jetzt schon beim dritten irgendwie
den magen verderben dass ich die anderen
nicht probieren kann ich auch abreißen
vielleicht auch wenn es bei ihnen aus
[Musik]
hmm also schmeckt nicht wie zuckerguss
aber es schmeckt jetzt auch nicht so wie
weiße schokolade klar es ist vegan
das ist dann auch ein bisschen
schwieriger aber so wie man kann die
daten sehr weit oben ist so ist werden
wir fragen beantwortet welche
verhütungsmethode verwendest du also da
muss jetzt erstmal hier der nächste
strawberry sprenkel ich habe seit ich 14
bin die pille genommen
aber ich habe das gefühl da manchmal die
zeit noch anders da wollt also jetzt
werden vielmehr darüber aufgeklärt wie
schädigende ist und damit so wusste man
das auch aber es war so
selbstverständlich dass man die pille
genommen hat für pickel mit 14
dass ich auch sagen muss dass ich in
jungen jahren als es dann mit sexuellen
erfahrungen losging
ich wusste dass kondome schützen und
dass man auch aufpassen muss wegen
geschlechtskrankheiten aber wenn man
dann ein freund hat oder so dann war das
relativ früh so ja der hat ja nur bis
der hat ja nur mit der un der rumgemacht
oder der hat er ja nur was mit der da
war das noch so da konnte man das
überblicken wenn man auch gerade im dorf
auf dem dorf aufwächst bisschen
unspektakulär und er bekommt hier nicht
so ganz durch
naja und dann konnte man halt nicht
schwanger werden deswegen war das öfter
mal so wir vermuten schon manchmal mit
kondomen aber eigentlich hat man es kaum
gemacht und dann bin ich so eine
depressive verstimmungen gekommen so und
dann hat irgendjemand mal gesagt moment
mal
nimmst du die bilder vielleicht liegt es
an der pille und das war vor vier jahren
ungefähr
und dann habe ich die letzten vier jahre
mit kondomen verhütet ganz normal so
mancher jungen machen sollte und jetzt
bin ich grad am überlegen es gibt ja
verschiedene pillen
hier haben wir dort carmel hazel nat ich
liebe den sprung zwischen diesen zwei
themen verhütung und so und jetzt
erkläre ich euch wie es funktioniert ja
und jetzt will dann überlegen weil es
gibt ja die pille die mit östrogen ist
und es gibt die pille die mit aus
östrogen ist und das ist die die auch
thrombose und herzkrankheiten hätten
faktisch sogar mein gewissen ist
wirklich ganz ganz nah
bitte nicht darauf festlegen dies halt
mit hormonen und bzw
der aus östrogen habe ich den satz noch
beenden oder schon mal bei ist na ja und
ich nehme jetzt diese variante diese
minipille die man auch durch nimmt bzw
informiere ich mich gerade drüber und
überlege sie anzufangen und die hat
nicht so viele nebenwirkungen also ich
will jetzt auch nicht werbung dafür
machen sagen oder das gewässer
verhütungsmethode weil es ist am ende
immer noch diverse tötungsmethode wenn
der mann sich darum kümmert und man ein
kondom benutzt
ganz starker kandidat wow wow wow wow
das ist irgendwie auch schwer darüber zu
sprechen also ich hab mal so in meinem
alter ich bin auch nicht so alt aber in
meinem alter ist es schon leichter aber
wenn ich so an damals denke dann ist man
auch so davon ausgegangen klar die frau
kümmert sich darum aber der mann muss
sich halt auch darum kümmern wenn man in
der festen partnerschaft ist kann man
sich halt mit kondomen auch und kann
sich krankheiten zu übertragen ohne
kondom
deswegen muss es machen oder man teste
sicherheit gut cook dass man auch nichts
hat es gibt ja auch krankheit niemanden
gar nicht sieht und man muss halt selber
für sich ausprobieren was geht es gibt
ja auch noch ringe und diaphragma sieht
aus wie so ein hütchen kann man auch
noch einsetzen
aber alles was so bin ich auch immer
noch an team inspirations tasse weil
alles was so reingepackt und wieder
rausgeholt und so dass wir noch sehr
schwer hier haben wir ein mit dieser
veganen schokolade weko gefüllt kennt
ihr lieben und ich glaube puderzucker
drauf
wow
oh mein gott ich muss einfach nur
pervers ein klein bisschen schmeckt aber
wie nutella muss man einfach sagen ich
habe das talent wenn ich schokolade esse
und ich mir auch richtig mühe gebe es
landet immer was an meinen mundwinkeln
es ist ein ruck banken video wenn ihr
das nicht sehen können dann tun wir das
auch an dieser stelle einfach leid so
nächste frage
nächste frage wie kriege ich meinen
kreis rum ohne mir sicher zu sein dass
er auf mich steht
ich habe das beste job der welt dazu
gesehen und zwar stellst du ein handy
auf und films dich während du deinem
crash sagst dass du aufstehst wenn es zb
dein bester freund du möchtest die
freundschaft nicht kaputt machen
und je nachdem wie die person reagiert
kannst du also wenn sie zum beispiel
sagt ohne dich also ich will nur meine
freunde sein
hier ist übrigens ein peanut butter
donath ich zeige dir nochmal so war in
seiner ganzen schönheit voix und je
nachdem wie er reagiert und er sagt dass
nur freunde für mich das sagen ja das
wiederum bringt lässt sich streiten
video
ich wollte ich nur austricksen sehr
vollmundig der airbus mutter lass dich
also wenn ich nicht so ein freund von
hermès gibt dass es dieses drei stufen
höher also noch mal ein bisschen auf
gelevelt sah ich bin drin ich bin jetzt
jetzt bin ich richtig und dr sommer
modus auch gute frage was dein
lieblingsessen
ganz klar ich glaube es wurde mit doktor
sommer nicht so ganz verstanden fragt
mich was kann mich nicht damit abfinden
dass mein bei auch andere frauen
attraktiv findet
finde das ist ein ich finde das ist ein
cookie dough wow das ist ein bisschen
gottvater cookie tod hat also sie das
team jetzt mit funcom guckt mal das
sollte ursprünglichen loch sein sie
haben sich nur gedacht dieser vettel
cookie dough der da oben
ich finde wenn männer andere frauen
attraktiv finden
völlig in ordnung absolut in ordnung gar
kein problem aber ich will davon nichts
hören
das ist pervers dass also ich will
nichts davon hören ich will nichts davon
haben wenig attraktiv findet das ist
absolut seine privatsphäre
andererseits muss sich timo bei mir
immer anhören wie toll ich alle kay
popstars vorne aber das sage ich auch
nicht neben ihm klar haben wir so einen
job mit gin dass sich jetzt ein
pappaufsteller habe demichelis'
geschenkt hat und wie schwer mir auch so
für die aber das ist so eine sonne super
super super star schwärmerei briten mit
karamell
[Musik]
das ist super schön aber wenn er mir
jetzt irgendwie sagen würde dass
irgendein -influenza girl oder
irgendjemand außen noch erreichbaren
bereich wenn er den attraktiv findet um
mir das auch so sagen würde
ich weiß dass in berlin sagt man
irgendwie egal wo du bist in zwei meter
entfernung befindet sich nach hatte
irgendwann mal gehören heißt aber nicht
dass ich gerne sehen möchte wo diese
ratte ist das sind zwei ganz eindeutig
unterschiedliche sachen
und wenn dein freund nicht aufhören kann
die zu zeigen weil wenn er so attraktiv
findet oder so dann solltest du mit ihm
auch ganz klar das gespräch suchen und
sagen ja egal du brauchst neben mir
nicht schwer
nehmen wir nicht sagen wer gut aussieht
das würde mich aufregen allgemein ist er
sowieso es ist ja sowieso kommunikation
ist das a und o und das schlimmste ist
und das hat sehr also haben halt viele
dieses gefühl von ach das kann ich nicht
ansprechen weil dann könnte ja
schlechter form von mir denken oder und
mich weniger mögen oder keine ahnung es
könnte unsere beziehung gefährden
aber dann ist es auch irgendwo nicht die
richtige beziehungsweise dann muss sein
an dieser beziehung an sich auch
zweifeln und nicht nur daran wie du was
sagen darfst damit der andere sich immer
pudelwohl fühlt es geht am ende immer
noch darum für dich dass du glücklich
bist und ganz viele leute verlieren sich
in beziehungen in diesem gefühl ich muss
den anderen glücklich machen und der
muss glücklich sein und er muss sich gut
fühlen und die ganze zeit muss alles
toll sein
für die person und dann leidet man
selber darunter ich meine ich hab meine
erfahrungen gemacht werden wir so ein
bisschen auftritt folgen ist keine
ahnung so durch die blume oder dass ich
so durch die blume gesagt habe
verstanden hat weiß dass ich meine
erfahrung gemacht habe und ich hab aber
genauso reagiert ich immer gedacht hat
die person hat aber ein problem und dem
der mainz ja nicht so böse und nee ich
war immer sehr unglücklich und habe
immer gedacht ja irgendwie muss ich das
ja schon regeln und ich muss damit klar
kommen und ich muss irgendwas machen das
ist halt
der person gut geht das ist es halt
nicht wenn du keine ahnung und wenn es
hat kleine sachen sind wenn du befindest
dich todes aufregt dass du das wär die
socken immer an diesen platz packt wurst
dich wo es was dich stört dann solltest
du nicht sofort ausreisen sagen oh mein
gott sondern einfach mal sagen happy ist
es echt wichtig dass du das machst weil
mich stört das extrem und wenn du es
nicht machst dann gibt mir das gefühl
gibt mir das gefühl dass du auf meine
bedürfnisse überhaupt nicht eingehe ist
oder die meine bedürfnisse nicht wichtig
genug sind und ich glaube es gibt ja
viele beziehungen draußen wo gerade wenn
man auf zickler unterwegs sondern also
das hat mein partner liegen lassen das
hat mein partner liegen lassen ich bin
auch ein sehr ordentlicher mensch und
timo ist von uns beiden der der vielmehr
auf ordnung und darauf achtet dass alles
irgendwie seinen platz liegend
ordentlich aussieht und ich würde aber
niemals mich darauf ausruhen sagen so
bin ich halt sondern ich würde ich
arbeite dran beziehungsweise gebe ich
mein bestes dass er sich wohlfühlt und
ich mit meinen aktionen ihm das gefühl
geben kann hey ich bin zwar chaotisch
extrem aber mir ist es nicht unwichtig
dass du dich dabei also das ist oder
oder ich möchte dass du weißt es mir
deine bedürfnisse wichtig sind und ich
versuche dass ich das besser machen kann
und da ist es dann ja die aufgabe von
dem partner ein bestes zu geben ich weiß
nicht wie ich das so auf den punkt
bringen soll aber ich glaube ich habe
das schon ganz gut gesagt was ich meine
es ging um attraktivität und was ich
gemerkt habe in meinen erfahrungen
beziehungen bedeutet arbeit in
beziehungen wird dir nichts es gibt wie
es gibt nicht eine beziehung die nicht
auf ganz kurz wow
es gibt nicht die beziehung in der
einfach alles super läuft und wenn du
jetzt so eine beziehung hast und
schreiben ist dort gibt's bei mir dann
ist das mega dann bist du halt eine
ausnahme aber es jede beziehung bedeutet
arbeit und arbeit nicht im sinne von wir
müssen von 5 bis 7
hier zusammen formular ausfüllen sondern
einfach wir müssen wenn wir uns streiten
nicht einfach wahllos streiten sondern
einfach auch mal gucken was können wir
in unserem verhalten ändern ganz auf das
man so sein verhalten drin und denkt
sich so ja so bin ich halt und versuche
ich mich zu ändern aber ich glaube es
geht gar nicht eher um dieses versuche
mich nicht zu ändern oder ich lasse mich
doch nicht von ihm am ändern aber
vielleicht kann ich mein verhalten
anpassen dass man besser zusammen klar
kommt und das weite feld sogar
glücklicher werden
hier ist was mit cremen damit
höhe milchreis oh mein gott das ist
milchreis in der mitte
strange strangers einen veganen will ich
es mal zu essen
ich weiß gar nicht wann ich das letzte
mal milchreis hatte woher weiß ich dass
er oder sie der die richtige ist
ich glaube den einen richtigen gibt's
nicht ich glaube es wenn wenn sich
jemand anfühlt wie der oder die richtige
dann ist es bei der oder die sich mühe
geben und ich nicht mehr
selbstverständlich sehen und ich glaube
sobald jemand dich selbstverständlich
sieht dann merkt also dann
dann funktioniert nichts dann ist alles
scheiße also diese
selbstverständlichkeit macht glaube ich
sehr viel kaputt und wenn dir jemand das
gefühl gibt dass du nicht wichtig bist
und das so selbstverständlich da bist
und da sich nichts daran aendert und
denner und die person noch nix machen
muss dafür dass du da bist wird sie auch
nichts machen solche leute fühlen sich
dann glaube ich an be oder das ist nicht
der die richtige und dann ist es glaube
ich noch ein faktor wie man es also hier
boston prim
es ist da noch ein faktor in was für
einer lebenssituation man sich befindet
weil es könnte sich jemand anfühlen wie
der die richtige aber keine zieht um
er beginnt ein studium in einer anderen
stadt und plötzlich ist er nicht mehr
der die richtige weil wenn ihr das
bedürfnis haben die person mit der er
zusammen seid öfter zu sehen als ein mal
im monat
dann wird es nicht funktionieren und es
funktioniert nicht weil ich nicht genug
liebt sondern weil deine bedürfnisse
befriedigt sind und bedürfnisse
befriedigen ist sehr wichtig das ist zum
beispiel bedürfnis was hier gerade
absolut befriedigt wird
boston cream in wigan himmlisch das ist
eine gute frage die eigentlich an den
care gestellt werden sollte merken kerle
überhaupt wenn frauen rasieren
pickelchen im intimbereich
das thema rasieren und männer
beziehungsweise männer und frauen oder
ich weiß nicht ich kann halt nur von
hetero beziehungen von meinen
erfahrungen sprechen
deswegen tut mir leid wenn ich nicht
alle mit einschließen kann aber männer
merken einfach nichts und das ist so
meine komplette erfahrung nicht gefragt
habe
alles was man über alles was man sich in
seinem körper sorgen macht das ist das
checken die nicht gerade was zu rasieren
angeht das checken ihn nicht wo du
rasiert bist und wo nicht
natürlich wenn manche stellen sehr
behaart sind dann wird ihnen das
vielleicht auffallen aber und selbst
wenn sie es merken jetzt im intimbereich
gehe jetzt mal davon aus dass man
währenddessen büßen was merken sollte
die die sind dach dass sie nicht die
sind dann nicht darauf fokussiert und
wenn sie es merken dann ist wegen das
wirklich egal
das system dann egal und wir sind so
kritisch mit uns selbst und seinem
körper weil es glaube ich ein paar
toxische wenn er gibt dir halt wirklich
einem das gefühl vermitteln können dass
man perfekt sein muss oder eigentlich
kommt david druck aber er von sich
selber meistens und deswegen stresst
euch nicht gerade im winter geraden
lockdown wo mein gott da sind so viele
fragen und tipps wie frau ihren kopf
abschalten kann kann mich bei jackson
die richtig feiern lassen ich glaube
beim sex ist das wie bei einer
meditation wenn du an viele sachen denkt
kann so zum beispiel auch nicht
meditieren und meditieren ist ja nicht
nur kopf komplett ausschalten sondern
die gedanken einfach kommen und gehen
lassen und sich nicht darüber aufregen
dass man das hat aber wenn man wirklich
merkt so der arbeitstag oder irgendein
thema oder familienprobleme geht er
nicht aus dem kopf hilft es eigentlich
wenn man fantasie hat an etwas zu denken
ganz speziell was ein vielleicht richtig
gut gefällt
wenn man nur wenn man halt nicht so
hören wenn man lust darauf hat aber halt
nicht so gerade abschalten kann man
vielleicht anders denken was so waren
die luft plus auch wieder zurückholt was
macht man bei einem ersten date
überhaupt heutzutage spazieren gehen wie
ist das erste mal sex schmerzhaft aussah
mann ist super super super super super
super super entspannt und es ist der
absolut richtige mit dem du das machst
dann ist es ein bisschen besser dann ist
es nicht ganz so schmerzhaft wenn du
aber niemanden geräts der ich sag mal so
die ich für selbstverständlich hält der
wird nicht so vorsichtig damit umgehen
okay die die letzte frage für heute ich
glaube die interessiert uns alle erst
mal findest du es schwer das leben sich
an ein leben vor corinna zu erinnern ja
absolut es ist glaube ich ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen wie es ohne sein wird
und wie es sein wird wenn wir unsere
masken alle runter ziehen in die bahn
steigen oder im supermarkt sind oder auf
einem konzert ich das sehe ich noch in
weiter ferne aber ich freue mich schon
extrem darauf und hast du existenz
krisen studieren noch und weiß nicht
wohin das führen soll
da muss ich auch wieder meinen
buddhismus spiritualität ein bisschen
reinpacken
es geht gar nicht so krass darum zu
wissen wo das alles hinführt weil wenn
man das so sieht dann kasse halt auch in
zwei jahren von einem bus überfahren
worden sein
und wenn du dann irgendwie keine ahnung
etwas gemacht das was ich unglücklich
macht dann ist ja gut dann hast du den
letzten zwei jahren viele zeit damit
verbracht mich zu machen
es geht aber auch nicht darum dass jeder
sein hobby zum beruf machen soll und
irgendwie jeder tag wird sich anfühlen
wie ein spaziergang in einem blumenmeer
mit flügel die dich an zwitschern und
wisst ihr denken so kann ich auf jeden
tag verbringt
ich glaube das einzige was wir alle
wollen das heißt zufriedenheit und die
muss man aber sie in sich selber finden
das ist so banal hin gesagt aber es kann
man hinkriegen
man sollte sich sein leben so fühlen
dass es sich erfüllt anfühlt das muss
aber nicht heißen dass der job den du
machst die krasse erfüllung ist dass du
da ja dich komplett aus liebstes kanal
dann auch im privaten bereich kannst du
ja dann eine richtige erfüllung finden
und der beruf je nachdem was du halt
dann machst ist der mittel zum zweck
damit das leben
damit es schön gestalten kannst oder
damit du die ziele erreichen kannst die
du erreichen willst und wenn man gerade
studiert ist es glaube ich auch noch es
ist also einerseits kann man sich ja
dann überlegen was man danach machen
möchte aber man hat danach mehrere
möglichkeiten
aber ich glaube auch wenn man noch im
studieren ist und schon früh merkt das
ist das irgendwie gar nicht also das was
sie aufmerksam aufmerksamkeitsspanne
überhaupt nicht da ist weil einem das
thema so wenig interessiert ist das ein
zeichen auch von deinem körper oder dein
hirn dann interessiert mich überhaupt
nicht
es ist schon schwer schlimm genug dass
leute dann studiengänge anfangen mit
themen die sie anscheinend gar nicht
interessieren nur weil sie über
studieren wollen
es ist also ganz ehrlich wir leben in
deutschland wir haben hier ist so viele
möglichkeiten ich würde immer sagen
abbrechen und was neues anfangen hat mir
also nur aus meinen erfahrungen nicht
als als allheilmittel und dass jeder
darunter glücklich wird aber aus meinen
erfahrungen hätte ich hätte ich das
nicht so gemacht dann wäre ich nicht
jetzt hier wo ich bin und ich bin
glücklich wo ich gerade bin eure
aufmerksamkeit spannende zeit ganz ganz
gut was ihr machen wollte und was nicht
es gibt leute die können sich total in
mathe verlieren und finden das super und
interessieren sich dafür und lernen dazu
biologie physik erziehungswissenschaften
ernährungswissenschaften park irgendwo
wissenschaften drauf da man man hat
schon irgendwie so ein ding
und manchmal ist es aber auch vielleicht
nicht so klar
aber ich glaube wenn man mal so ganz
dann neutral sein leben schaut und guckt
das mach ich denn eigentlich echt gerne
was was fällt mir zum beispiel besonders
leicht wenn ich zum beispiel richtig gut
mit kindern ja kann ich mir vielleicht
vorstellen das zu meinem beruf zu machen
oder bin ich richtig geschickt mit den
händen dann sollte ich vielleicht
überlegen ein handwerk zu machen auch
wenn es kein studium erfordert
vielleicht braucht jemand studium ich
weiß dass immer so also früher wenn es
noch in praktika suchen und so was gegen
keinen gegner ist immer schnell darum
okay wie viel könnte man darin
wie viel kriegt man im ersten jahr vom
ausbildungsjahr und das ist aber so ein
bisschen der trugschluss weil wir wollen
geld ist nicht das was wir alle streben
und viel geld haben ist nicht das was am
ende ist das sinnvollste ist wir wollen
alle einfach nur zufriedenheit und wir
glauben dass durch das geld diese
zufriedenheit kommt aber das passiert
leider nicht es tut mir leid dass ihr
euch diesen zahn ziehen muss ich habe
erfolg auf youtube gehabt und alle meine
finanziellen sorgen haben sich aufgelöst
ich hatte große finanzielle ist also ich
rief ihr wird finanzielle sorgen und ich
war so unglücklich wie noch nie also das
ist schon wieder lange her aber ich war
so unglücklich wie noch nie und ich
dachte mir ich kann mir doch jetzt alles
kaufen ich habe doch alles was ist denn
jetzt das problem und es gibt immer
irgendein neues problem und das ich war
so unzufrieden und wobei ich aber dachte
hey preisgeldes ich finde doch jetzt
zufrieden sein und das ist halt diese
große lügen wir uns alle irgendwie
gegenseitig erzählen das ist das geld so
wird schon die zufriedenheit bringen
weil dann kann man sich ja das auto
kaufen oder die handtasche oder diese
schuhe weil man denkt dass die einem
zufriedenheit bringen aber die werden
wir auch nicht zufriedenheit bringen
vielleicht zu kurz und dann wirst du
wieder merken da ja mit dem es immer
noch das gleiche oder meinen partner ist
immer noch beschließen auch wenn ich
diese geile schuhe trage das ist nur so
ein kleiner rat von mir jetzt sehr
intensiv noch zum enden geworden so ich
bringe jetzt diese donuts weg ich hoffe
euch hat das video gefallen wenn wir sie
nutzen ist nicht immer wieder nächsten
mittwoch dann wieder
und eigentlich hatte ich heute ein
anderes video geplant aber das hat
leider nicht mehr funktioniert das kommt
aber dann nächste woche und ich hoffe
ihr freut euch darauf und ja froh dass
donuts macht euch glücklich bis zehn
leute was hat sie zu meiner neuen mal
wand malt man an einem ort